The WHO says there are no
proven effective therapeutics
to be had for the new coronavirus.
Efforts are focused on
detection and containment.
A vaccine is still at
least 12 to 18 months away.
As the coronavirus pandemic escalates
knowing we have such
a long wait until we can immunise
can be pretty scary.
The coronavirus that causes
COVID-19 is a new virus and
attacks cells in a new way so
we need a new drug to tackle it.
That said, there might already
be a drug ready to use,
we just don't know it yet.
Using pre-approved drugs is the best
strategy in the short term to help people
as others develop maybe more
sophisticated targeted approaches,
say with a vaccine, or with
drugs that target the virus.
But that could take months, if not years.
Professor Nevan Krogan works with
an international team of scientists
that have identified pre-existing
drugs with the potential
to fight the coronavirus.
What we've noticed here is
that this virus, in a very
interesting way, is coming in and
essentially hijacking all the
major biological processes in the
cell, in a very fascinating way.
So it's getting its fingers in pretty
much all the major machinery in our cells.
So the virus needs our cells
and our genes and proteins,
in order to live and replicate
and infect ourselves.
So the question is,
what are those proteins?
So we generated this
map, this blueprint where
we're essentially, looking
for all the human proteins
connected to virus proteins.
We identified 332 of these human
proteins, through this study.
And predicted drugs, or compounds
that would come and bind to and
inhibit these human proteins.
So of the 69 that we predicted
to bind at least one of these
332 proteins, 27 of which
are FDA-approved drugs and the
rest are in clinical trials, or
being looked at pre-clinically.
The logic here is if we do get
a hit on one of these drugs
we can go and look at one of
these drugs in more detail and
then see what other drugs, or
compounds are similar to it.
So we can expand our search
space, based on this initial
screen at the end of the day.
Which will give us hopefully a
higher likelihood of success.
Give us a sense of why it's easier to use
an old drug?
I think on average it takes
eight, nine years to get a drug
into a person and a big reason
for that length of time is that you
have to go through toxicity trials.
But if you focus on drugs, or
compounds, that have already
passed that barrier. You can
more quickly expedite a particular
drug, or compound, into a
person to target this virus.
And a lot of times that's not
done, this drug repurposing.
One of the reasons is,
financially related.
Companies have patents for specific
compounds, or drugs and if another company
finds that, oh, this drug could
be used for another disease.
Well the original company
will get all the financial
benefit from that.
So people don't look at
those in that way that much.
But of course now everybody just wants to
solve this particular problem.
And I would say one of the classic
examples of drug repurposing is Viagra.
It was initially used to treat heart pain
and then it was realized there were other
beneficial effects associated with it.
So we'd been thinking
about this for some time.
and obviously now, with
this sense of urgency, it's
really allowed us to expedite
this particular vision and test it.